[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à toutes pour cette
nouvelle émission dans vie de lecture la
lecture c'est pas neutre comme disait
eric orsenna la lecture nous a grandi la
lecture nous en sommes or nous allons
essayer de vous enchanter avec des
livres nathalie vol que maître de
conférences à l'uivc ce qu on va nous
parler d'un livre de natel à hawthorne
je pense que je viens dit la lettre
écarlate oui merci bernard détachées
donc c'est un livre de nathaniel
hawthorne et c'est un classique de la
littérature américaine que j'ai envie de
me remettre à l'honneur alors un tout
petit mot sur l'auteur c'est un écrivain
américain qui est né au tout début du
19e siècle à salem une ville du
massachusetts qui est connu pour ses
procès en sorcellerie
voilà les sorcières de salem et c'est un
livre qui est publié en 1845 et
l'histoire se passe deux cents ans plus
tôt à boston et elle débute par la
sortie de prison d'une femme qui
s'appelle esther queen et qui arrive sur
la place du marché
elle reçoit sur la place du marché sa
sentence et esther devra porter cousue
sur son corsage et bien la lettre a a
comme adultère cette condamnation a
apporté la lettre écarlate la désignant
comme une femme adultère évidemment la
désigne comme une femme victime des lois
de son époque de l'amérique puritaine du
xviie siècle mais esther elle n'a pas le
comportement uniquement d'une victime
c'est une femme qui a beaucoup d'alluré
beaucoup de caractère qui est
extrêmement dignes et qui va tenir tête
à ses juges en refusant de dévoiler
l'identité du père de l'enfant donc
c'est une histoire qui est très forte
c'est un livre admirable qui tient à des
personnages qui sont très puissants qui
sont très bien dessiné il vraiment une
subtilité
l'auteur va chercher dans l'est dans les
recoins vraiment de l'âme humaine est ce
que j'ai trouvé très réussie dans ce
livre c'est que au fond on
un auteur qui nous offre une avec la
lettre écarlate une magnifique héroïne
une héroïne qui va assumer ses actes et
qui va vivre dans la solitude totale
avec sa fille la fille qui est née de
cet adultère et elle va vivre avec une
grande dignité
elle vit avec une grande dignité et au
milieu d'un mari qui est blessé qui est
dévorée par l' envie de se venger et un
amant extrêmement lâches qui par
ailleurs est un clergyman de la ville
qui adulé par ses fidèles et qui ne
dévoilera jamais son identité donc c'est
le seul personnage qui va s'en sortir la
tête haute et je crois que ce livre
mérite d'être lu orly il a été écrit il
ya 200 ans quand même et il y a
plusieurs et coup peut-être trois très
vite
d'abord le féminisme c'est un livre
féministe une héroïne qui est vraiment
féministe et avec ce type de littérature
trouve qu'on est loin de certaines
d'associations qui aujourd'hui me
paraissent un peu caricatural et je
crois en luttant contre ce combat
indispensable égalité hommes femmes
parfois le rendre un peu contre
productif je crains que et bien nous
ayons c'est nous continuons une
segmentation de la société où les femmes
et les hommes pourraient vivre comme des
adversaires
donc le féminisme le puritanisme relire
ce livre parce que nous sommes quand
même à l'heure d'un renouveau du
puritanisme notamment aux etats-unis
dans certaines facultés américaines on
voit certaines idéologies extrêmement
forte et en france aussi en matière de
culture
on voit bien qu'un nouvel ordre moral se
dessiner c'est dangereux pour la liberté
de création la liberté d'expression
auxquels nous sommes attachés et enfants
c'est un livre qui fait écho à la rumeur
au lynchage contemporain c'est un livre
sur la rumeur publique et aux je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on peut mettre très
facilement au pilori quelqu'un avec les
réseaux sociaux et on peut dévaster des
vies donc c'est une ville extrêmement
bout d'un point de vue littéraire et je
trouve qu'il ya des échos et on peut
peut-être grâce à ce livre mieux
comprendre notre monde contemporain
merci l'année nous allons passer en
autriche avec stefan zweig qui a un des
plus grands auteurs touchent est très lu
en france avec la confusion des
sentiments
alors oui on va parler de la confusion
des sentiments de stefan zweig
le livre est là bas et c'est en fait
c'est un des
un des grands succès de ce bug c'était à
la fois on peut dire un court roman ou
une longue nouvelle commande comme
hambourg à l'apprécier qui a eu un
succès fulgurant à l'époque quand il est
sorti en 1927
parce que c'est le sujet traité qui
était un petit peu chaud c'était les
relations d'amour en train entre un père
et un fils ou un train à m et son
disciple
dans le cas de l'université enfin on
faisait on faisait on faisait venir à la
littérature le traitement un peu de
l'homosexualité entre deux hommes
entrent pas en particulier alors pour
dire pour dire un petit peu de
l'histoire c'est l'histoire au soir de
sa vie d'un vieux professeur qui se
remémore son aventure qu'il avait eu à
19 ans lorsqu'il a gagné l'université il
a gagné l'université il était un
étudiant impertinent railleur avec toute
l'ivresse de la vie vous les voulez
entendre parler que de ça et c
il avait des relations très difficiles
avec son père qui était glaciale avec
lui mais son père devant devant cette
hécatombe de dinan étude de fait le leur
prend leur prend en main et l'envoie
dans une petite université à berlin est
là dans cette petite université il fait
la connaissance de son maître c'était
d'ailleurs un professeur de philologie
philologie c'est l'étude de la langue et
puis de la littérature de la langue il
fait il fait connaissance de son maître
un homme à l'éloquence
radieuse d'une culture profonde etc qui
magnétise ces étudiants qui le magnétise
lui qui lui propose de l'héberger dans
sa grande maison où il a des petits des
petites chambres de bonnes ou des choses
comme ça et de l'année une relation
entre son maître et son disciple
admirait alors il est où il est tout fou
d'amour étouffe ou d'admiration pour son
maître mais le m inexplicablement de
temps en temps est complètement doux
avec lui et de temps en temps le cos
magistralement etc
alors il fait connaissance de la femme
du maître qui a une quinzaine d'années
de moins que lui qui elle n'est pas du
tout dans la culture dans les
littératures et tout ça qui est au
contraire une belle gymnase il devient
son amant et puis par le fait de par le
fait de l'amour avec la femme de son
maître il découvre le secret de son
maître
même si la confusion des sentiments
étaient bien lu par beaucoup de gens
tout ça ben je n'en dis pas plus pour ne
pas développer mais bon il faisait pas
trop comment finir mais voilà donc
cessons les relations amoureuses
dissimulé entre un maître sans dissiper
son maître dans le cas de l'université
d'un jeune étudiant de 19 ans stéphane
que le talon alors j'ai pour ma part je
voudrais vous parler un peu de poésie
avec 6 il coupe ce que ça va plaire à
saisir la poésie donc cécile coulaud
qu'il ne viole l est de l est né en 1990
sans nouvelles et ce qui est bien c'est
qu'elle aurait pu s'installer à paris
mais elle reste à clermont ferrand et
avec son ouvrage poétique les ronces en
prose libre en poésie libre elle a gagné
le prix apollinaire
elle a fait un roman aussi le bateau
paradis qui vient de gagner le prix du
monde donc c'est vraiment un auteur de
talent un espèce de sagan françois
delerm enfin c'est vraiment quelqu'un je
vous lire un poème del mon amour c'est
la fièvre qui parle avec ses lèvres
crever d'avoir aussi soif calcia mourens
une marche d'escalier avec son corps
brisé en travers des draps tremper ses
plaintes tranchait par des larmes
brûlante
nous n'avons plus l'habitude d'avoir mal
cette nuit mon amour c'est la fièvre qui
parle de toutes ces histoires qui n'ont
rien à faire dans la nôtre de tous ceux
qui n'ont pas leur place près de ce feu
que tu as de ce feu qui réchauffe
tu sais bien que le monde entier ne
tient pas dans ma gorge
ces tempêtes mais tous
que je ne peux pas garder longtemps pour
moi les infidélités des autres mon amour
c'est la fièvre qui gronde
avec ses longs yeux clos brûlé par la
lumière du jour avec ses doigts craquer
autour d'un auriez trop lourd nous
écrase des narines fumantes
j'entends dehors les hommes qui n'ont de
la rue de leurs sanglots
c'est la fièvre qui sentent mon amour je
n'ai pas réussi à retrouver à retrouver
les langes de mon berceau
je n'ai pas réussi à prendre la hauteur
nécessaire
je n'ai pas su jouer à la guerre mon
corps et mon tobo hill grace plus fort
qu'un parquet de bois sec
je ne supporte plus les assauts du
quotidien le désespoir solide des
employés de bureau je ne sais plus faire
avec où mon amour tu me tiens dans ton
bec
il faudra partir loin il faudra partir
bientôt pour mettre du sang frais dans
les nervures de la bête pour corriger
nos pires défauts des chagrins d'avant
la naissance me hante parfois je les
vois je bossais jusqu'à toi tu te tiens
droite derrière des élégances commune
raid protégé par les douves de son
château mon amour c'est la fièvre qui
parle je ne raffole pas des aventures je
préfère tremblé sur le poids des
couvertures et murmurer aux animaux des
mots doux que j'ai honte de prononcer un
mot sans âme est semblable mon amour
avant toi j'étais cet animal à moitié
fou dans le fond d'une étable nourri par
l'orage et la brume endormi sous les
poutres français tu attends du ta main
et tu m'as relevé voilà il ya une
trentaine comme ça mais celui-ci va nous
parler de son d'un auteur qu'il connaît
bien avec son le dernier roman la
demoiselle fait d'accuser maltret
évidemment je connais l'auteur parce que
c'est mon 17e livre voilà donc un livre
tous les ans rien de très intéressant
alors c'est un thème ou une très
intéressante j'ai bien peur qu'il soit
parfois un petit peu actuelle puisque je
parle dans les années 60 nous avions
parfois et même souvent les directrices
est ce qu'on appelait les cours
complémentaire à l'époque qui n'était
pas des tentes
et mademoiselle on disait mademoiselle
on ne savait même pas si elle avait
annoncé elle avait une vie de famille
c'était mademoiselle et voilà
mademoiselle dans un endroit qui pour
moi est magnifique dans les monts
d'arrée vers ul gars ul boîte
voilà tout près de de la forêt
d'huelgoat de tout ce qui fait son
charme et sa beauté et elle dirige donc
un cours complémentaire de jeunes filles
droit droite dans ses chaussures droite
je peux pas dire dans ses bottes parce
que ça n'est pas la règle et elle a
parmi ses élèves une petite fille qui
entre en sixième qui travaillent bien
mais qui a un problème important
elle a un pied bot c'est à dire un pet
de travers et elle ne peut pas suivre
elle ne peut pas marcher comme tout le
monde et mademoiselle tout au long du
livre va essayer de la faire marcher
comme tout le monde
seulement il existe quand même des
impossibilités et l'impossibilité elle
est qu' elle ne fera pas de gymnastique
elle est obligée d'être dans un univers
clos qui est une salle seule voie là où
on entend les chuchotements de là la
rivière d'argent qui est tout à fait en
bas et cette petite fille bien sûr vit
dans une famille en famille ou dia deux
filles une fille qui est normal
et cette petite la mer les entoure de
toute son affection
mais c'est difficile à comprendre et
puis la règle est la règle voilà les au
cours complémentaire c'est comme ça à
autrement et puis on va arriver à un
moment où elle va pouvoir peut-être se
faire opérer voilà mes
mademoiselle jusqu'au sera ce qu'elle
est mademoiselle sans concession sans
affection et sans tendresse pour aucune
d'elle et on arrivera à la fin du livre
dont même si sur ces 6 et sur tv fils je
ne vous dévoilerai pas merci suzy nous
allons vous donner c'est cette envie de
lecture c'est un livre à lire pour la
nouvelle année 2020 c'est dit et unicité
touch éditée chez unicité j'ai souvent
plusieurs
plusieurs maisons d'édition qui veulent
mes livres parce que je pense que comme
je suis poète mais comme je suis aussi
romancière et nouvelliste
il veille ceci vous suzy merci à toutes
et à tous de nous avoir écoutés mais au
revoir à la prochaine émission envies de
lecture
merci
[Musique]